well ahead of mr biden's first foreign
trip to europe the munich security
conference has released a report
saying the west needs to prepare for a
period of systemic
competition with authoritarian powers
presenting the report in berlin veteran
german diplomat wolfgang is
said that western democracies need to
pull together in the face of an
increasingly assertive
china and russia in a dw exclusive our
chief international editor richard
walker
spoke with wolfgang issner and asked him
what systemic competition with these
countries is likely to look like
china has come out of hiding china was a
reluctant
player on the global scene until very
recently now they have
shown their muscles and we need to deal
with that and this is why
of course there will have to be at least
from a german point of view
continued cooperation on selling
hopefully a good number
of of german automobiles to china but
there will have to be a different
element also in terms of
competition on what means
power what defines power and influence
and that means war and peace uh in the
21st century and that
is actually the new element here where
we will have cooperation
not only on trade like automobiles but
also on climate protection on
preventing climate change on preventing
terrorism on
preserving non-proliferation in nuclear
issues
and hopefully advancing arms control etc
etc
but also in pushing back against
authoritarian regimes like
you know the one-party chinese state
which is
based on entirely different ideas than
our kinds of western democracies
so it's going to be a very challenging
future
environment for policymakers but also
for the public
do you think the publics around europe
for instance are ready for this are they
up for this period of competition our
leaders need to make sure that the
message
which the public receives that the
message works
and and is coordinated with the message
that our partners
convey to their own publics that
requires first and foremost
because we know that the united states
has a china policy
they know what they want to achieve with
china
they've defined it
do we have in the european union a
coordinated
china policy does the european union
speak with one voice
on china can our partner in washington
define what is the eu position on china
not really so far
we reflect on germany it is its economy
is highly dependent on china
and its security is utterly dependent on
the united states
if we think forward through this century
can
that position be sustained of course our
preference will probably not be
identical to that of the united states
but as i try as i tried to say before
first
our first job our first element of
homework has to be
to figure out a coordinated
joint european position with which we
can then go to washington and say
can we talk about this where is overlap
of interest where is
identity of interest where are
difficulties
where we find it very difficult to agree
that's the way to go forward
we need to be of course on
on the transatlantic side of things when
it comes to china
but i don't think that we we will always
find ourselves
in the in the in a in that we will
always define our interests
exactly identical to the definition that
our american friends arrive in
afghanistan many thanks thank you